we are hearing more this morning about
the plight of two young Syrian girls
caught up in one of the government's
bloodiest sieges of the country's
seven-year Civil War nor and al-khatib
live in rebel-held eastern goethe where
more than four hundred people have been
killed in six days Charlie d'Agata spoke
with Noor and Allah's mother he's
following developments from London
Charlie good morning good morning and we
were able to speak with the family this
morning and everyone is safe but they
didn't get much sleep explosions
continued throughout the night and they
say they're too terrified to step foot
outside their apartment by the hour the
ferocious bombardment of eastern gouda
crept ever closer to the neighborhood of
10 year old Noor and her eight-year-old
sister Allah until one airstrike sent
shards of glass and debris through their
apartment slashing a laws forehead we
got through to their terrified mother
shams a khateeb after the blast I know
some zone I know you're in danger I can
hear that I can see it and her message
when we spoke to her again this morning
and freedom please help us the two
little girls had taken to Twitter to
tell the world about their plight
[Music]
speaking in English nor says so more
people would listen the children of
Goethe before it's too late
they're among 400 thousand civilians
living through a merciless onslaught by
russian-backed Syrian forces who insists
they're targeting Islamic extremists who
continue to fire rockets into the
capital trapped inside what the UN
describes as hell on earth UN
discussions of a ceasefire so far been
installed by Russia's State Department
spokesperson Heather now irt's struggle
to provide any answers to stop the
violence
telling journalists I don't know what
some of you expect us to do Gail it's
very tough story thank you very much
charlie